alright here's how you can make fading
tunnels first you want to open parallax
fading tunnel set which you can find the
link to in the description of this video
and when you open it you want to go to
the straight fade piece and you have to
rotate it a couple of times until it's
black like that and basically when it's
black like this you can pretty much go
in your tunnel and don't worry about
it's not being high enough or not being
wide enough for the shape of your tunnel
you can basically place as many as you
need just to get that good fade in there
and make sure that if you do this if
you're doing it with a cave or with a
building it doesn't really matter but
make sure that your opening is large
enough to actually fit the tunnels in
since they are a full tile placement
objects and one thing which I like to do
is you can see that there's this middle
section and it looks a bit glitchy from
this side if you go like that so then I
want to get the straight black piece and
fill in that middle section in the same
way as I did with the fade there it goes
that's all black now and and this side
we can just pretty much get this fade in
and then we're good to go
and I just need to fill this in a bit on
the side don't worry too much about it
sticking out just a tiny bit on the
rocks it doesn't really matter and
doesn't really end up looking terrible
as long as you can see the fading of the
color on the walls or rocks that you
have on the side it works perfectly and
that's basically how it's done and for
diagonal tunnels and straight tunnels
this works in exactly the same way make
sure you have the straight fades on both
ends in the right direction and then you
could go and that's how easy it is to
make fading tunnels thank you for
watching